ناقله النفط اليمنيه صافر تهديد بيئي منذ
عام 2015
توقفت بالقرب من ميناء الحديده
تحمل مئات الاطنان من النفط الخام وان
ترسب فسيؤدي الى كارثه بيئيه هائله لتصبح
خامسه اكبر تسربا لخزان نفطي في التاريخ
الان وبعد ثمانيه اعوام الامم المتحده
ستبدا عمليه انقاذ ناقله صافر
عمليه تفريغ الناقله ستستغرق من اسبوع الى
شهر بناء على نوعيه النفط ومدى سهوله ضخه
هدف الامم المتحده الاول هو نقل النفط من
ناقله صافر الى السفينه نوتيكا وبعد ذلك
سيتم قطر ناقله الفارغه في عمليه تقدر
كلفتها ب 148 مليون دولار
العمليه لها مخاطر الخبراء ما زالوا بح
اجه لتحديد ما اذا كان هناك اكسجين داخل
خزانه النفط ما قد يؤدي الى انفجار في حال
تعرضها لشراره ما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات